est-ce que vous allez encore utiliser le
cellulaire au volant c'est cette
question posée lors de l'émission tout
le monde en parle dimanche dernier qui a
précipité la décision de dany turcotte
de quitter l'émission moi je pense que
c'est l'accumulation parce que on dirait
on y ont fait au 7 août
maintenant des petites garcia puis je
pense que cela passait comme les autres
moi je pense que c'est l'accumulation
ce qui est certain c'est que sa dernière
boutade déclenché une avalanche de
réactions négatives sur les réseaux
sociaux et l'indignation de certains
commentateurs
on s'est parlé beaucoup à lui et moi
puis je suis dans un message publié sur
facebook
dany turcotte explique avoir été
perturbée par plusieurs tempêtes de
médias sociaux vécus au cours des
dernières années
ma confiance est plus à perdre et et
j'en suis venu à être paralysés par la
peur de me tromper de poser la question
qui pue je pense que c'est un bon
diagnostic de notre époque dans le sens
que la sur les réseaux sociaux c'est de
plus en plus polarisé en salle en scène
une agressivité de plus en plus grande
et ça fait une première victime s'en
fera sûrement d'autres je trouve ça
dommage je trouve salim est un créateur
dans ce sens l'annoncé de son départ a
créé une onde de choc mais c'était bien
fait selon le conseiller en
communication et d'image de marque louis
aucoin et saignante surprise l'instant
un départ que beaucoup d'élégance a
répliqué en claquant la porte
en montrant du doigt mais c'est pour ça
qu'on a choisi de faire il choisit de le
faire avec élégance et en faisant simple
et contrôler le narratif de son départ
la direction de radio canada a confirmé
que dany turcotte ne sera pas remplacé
cette saison et que sa contribution au
succès de tout le monde en parle au
cours de dix sept dernières années sera
soulignée et on l'invité dimanche
prochain parce que j'ai aujourd'hui mais
je pense qu il est d'ores et déjà
confirmé que tout le monde en parle sera
de retour l'an prochain pour une 18e
saison ici nabi alexandre chartier radio
canada mme royal
[Musique]